14 defeats and now a late night
near rumble.
Kevin McCarthy
has that passed him
and he is now
speaker of the House
Did you hear him
say when he got up there.
I never thought I would get up here.
I mean there was that moment
and you contrast that to the confidence
that he exuded all day long all week.
Maybe
it was sort of a feigned appearance
to just kind of have a stiff upper lip.
But in reality, he until that moment,
I think we were all thinking,
will he actually become the speaker
of the House,
including, of course, a brawl.
Almost, almost, almost a brawl.
I mean, the
the quickness with which he was elated
and then he was
defeated and deflated
and then he was angry.
And then all of a sudden,
they convinced the at least
Matt Gates and for others
to change their votes
to vote present to lower the threshold
so that he could actually become speaker.
And to see him run down to the well
and say, hold on,
we don't want to adjourn.
All the red cards coming out.
Yeah.
I mean, it was
it was truly, truly dramatic.
I mean, we talked about this
being a historic
once in a century occurrence.
I think this will go down in history
for so many reasons,
not the least of which the 15 rounds
it took
to become the Speaker of the House.
The idea of all of the negotiating
and the jockeying behind the scenes.
But immediately it was as if the
of course,
Minority Leader Hakeem Jeffries,
all of whom
now are congresspersons
officially and longer elect
they knew where to pick up
just as McCarthy did, which is the the
the contrast
what the Democrats and the Republicans
would now do going forward. Yeah.
And it also went from chaos
to the typical pageant
pageantry and protocol that we
are used to seeing
when a new Congress begins.
It just
is it usually at one 45 in the morning,
although it is toast.
It is January 7th.
And this is around
I mean, small hours the morning.
Right, of what happened
when two years ago
on that sober anniversary they were all
Americans are really watching
what would happen in these very chambers.
I would go right now to Melanie
Zona who is on Capitol Hill.
Melanie,
you have been holding down the fort
over there. What happens next tonight?
If you can predict anything
at this point,
your members are going to go home
and get a lot of sleep, myself included.
Hopefully,
look, what's happening
next is they need to organize the house.
So they need to pass
what's known as a rules package.
But we are hearing that
they are going to wait
until Monday to do that.
They've had agreement
now after all of this resolution
with the speaker standoff.
And I just want to step back
for a moment, because for Kevin McCarthy,
this has been a lifelong dream.
He was working in politics.
His entire adult life.
He was denied the speakership in 20, 15.
He worked to court the conservative wing
ever since then.
He immediately got to work.
Strategizing is
how can I get the speakership one day?
And that is the moment we are in
after this messy, ugly
confrontation today.
All week, it was a rollercoaster.
He finally got there.
But this is going to be a position
that is significantly weaker
than the one
he probably envisioned
because in order to get the gavel,
he had to negotiate,
negotiate away so much of his power
And we still don't know
the full scope of the concessions
that he gave way.
I did catch up with Matt Gates briefly
to ask him what made him change his vote.
All he said is
I ran out of things to ask for
You know, there's
there were swirling
rumors swirling around
that he may have been given
a subcommittee gavel.
Kevin McCarthy denied that.
And Kevin McCarthy
did already gave so much away,
including this tool known
as the motion to vacate
the speaker's chair,
which means any single member
can call for a vote
to oust the sitting speaker.
So going forward, yes,
Kevin McCarthy has gotten
the speakership,
but the task, the tough task
now begins and that's governing.
And as we saw, it is going to be messy.
It is going to be difficult.
He has these warring wings of his party
that he is going to have to contend
with every single day.
Every single vote is going to be a battle
and a fight.
And so that is what we can expect
for the next two years
as Speaker
Kevin McCarthy takes the gavel.
I mean, Melanie,
I'm pretty sure that you've
won the negotiation
when you literally
have run out of things to ask for
and the other person
is just giving you the yeses.
I do wonder what the scope of everything
they've actually been able to concede
and get what that will ultimately be.
But as we're waiting to hear again
from the new speaker of the House
when he'll address reporters
outside of his office
we're getting some new reporting in
about what happened during that.
Very and we'll just call it
a heated moment that everyone leaned
into their television screens
to watch during that failed 14 vote.
What can you tell us about that moment?
That was just such an incredible moment.
I've been covering the Congress
for ten years.
I have never seen anything like that
on the House floor.
Before, but we are learning new details,
thanks to my colleague Andy Greer,
who is in the chamber
and was also working her sources
to figure out what happened.
And in this moment,
that moment is when
Kevin McCarthy realized
that he wasn't going to have the votes
because Rosendale had voted present.
And so
Kevin McCarthy was completely dejected.
You saw him
walk up
the aisle towards
where Boebert and Gates were sitting
and pleading with them to vote for him.
He was in a moment of desperation.
And then you saw Mike Rogers
coming up from behind the well
coming down the aisle.
And this is someone he's a chairman.
He is a close McCarthy ally.
He's been growing more frustrated
and more frustrated
with the holdouts all week.
So that is important context.
In fact,
we are told that he had threatened
to kick
some of the holdouts
off of their committee assignments
if they didn't fall in line.
So he was so frustrated.
He came down the aisle
and sources told Annie Greer
that he basically said,
Matt, you're finished to him
at that point.
Hudson, another member
came up behind him, sort of muzzled
him and tried to hold him back
so he wasn't able to speak any more.
But it really spoke to the moment of just
how tense things were
and how it looked like
it was all falling apart
for Kevin McCarthy,
but only almost as quickly
as it fell apart.
Things then came together.
We're told that leadership was
then informed that Gates was a yes,
and then there were instead of motioning
to adjourn,
there's another moment of chaos
where they switched their votes
and they were deciding
to do another speaker vote.
And then what ends up happening
is every single
one of those remaining
holdouts voted present.
So just a complete rollercoaster
of a vote of a day of a week, really.
Ever since the midterms, this
has been a rollercoaster
for Kevin McCarthy.
So a huge sigh of relief
for him and his allies tonight.
Hey, listen, Mayor,
adjourning right now, Melanie,
we're watching them on
with their emotion.
There are two in favor of the 118th
Congress now sworn into office
going home tonight.
Let's listen in.
Well, here
is right now
in the studio, we've got CNN chief
White House correspondent Phil Mattingly,
Tim Mitchell,
a Washington correspondent
for the Atlanta Journal Constitution,
and Liam
Donovan, former
National Republican
Senatorial Committee aide.
This is pretty amazing right now,
just the idea of being muzzled on that
on the actual house of the floor,
the threat.
What do you guys make of it?
I mean, that's just a good friend
right off the.
Knowing where that was going to head
the beauty of Mel's breakdown
is how eloquently she was going through
very complex
details of what
we've seen over the last four days.
I'll try and simplify it to some degree.
And I think at this table,
we probably have several decades
of experience covering
Capitol Hill and covering
that chamber in particular.
Nothing about the last four days
was normal.
Everything about the last 10 hours
was extraordinary.
And the biggest question now is, is this
just the way it's going to be?
Every single day for the next two years?
Or is this a moment where
there's not going to be a Kumbaya
unity type thing,
but people start to sit down
and realize we're going to have to start
to govern?
As Mel was saying,
and we're going to have to start
to figure out a way to make this work.
How you define making this work,
I think, is
a pretty open question right now,
because I can just tell you that nobody
I don't want
speak to the people at this table,
but literally
nobody thinks this is going to go well.
Everyone is not based
based on what we've seen.
And so I just
because there's a lot of questions
that come out of it.
And I think that's why we can break down,
you know,
all the intricacies
of the procedural things that happen.
But at the bottom line,
people have been watching from home
all week.
And to them, it looks like chaos.
To them, it looks like a complete mess.
And to them,
it looks like,
you know, another
symbol of government dysfunction
and it doesn't bode
well for the next two years.
Again, what Melanie said about
Speaker McCarthy
now giving away a lot of his power,
further empowering those far
right members
to really
be obstructionists
any time they want to be.
How is he going to get anything done?